It's been the kind of summer that makes it seem like the alarmists were right about everything. Heat waves and drought and wildfires across the West, hurricanes along the East Coast drowning people in their cars in New Jersey and in their basement apartments in New York.
这个夏天，让人们觉得末日论者说的一切似乎都应验了。热浪、干旱、横扫西部的野火，以及东海岸的飓风，让新泽西州坐在车里的人和纽约地下室公寓里的居民都被洪水淹没。
So yeah, climate change is real. And most Americans believe that is what we're seeing right now. But for most of us, including me, knowing that that is our future-- it doesn't change much for us. It's like knowing that you're going to die someday. Like, sure. True. And then you put it aside, go on with your day. But there are people out there who look at the same evidence that the rest of us do, and they just take it to heart in a way that most of us don't. They have a wake-up moment. Rebecca Huntley had one. Totally took her by surprise.
没错，气候变化是真实的。大多数美国人都相信我们现在目睹的就是事实。但对于我们大多数人，包括我在内，即使知道这就是我们的未来，生活也不会因此发生太多改变。这就像你知道自己终有一天会死一样。没错，这是事实。然后你把它抛之脑后，继续过你的日子。但有些人，他们看着和我们一样的证据，却以一种我们大多数人所没有的方式记在心上。他们经历了一个“觉醒时刻”。丽贝卡·亨特利就经历过一次，这完全让她措手不及。
So I'm a really early riser. I'm, like, a 5:30 AM riser, as I think a lot of moms are, because it's sometimes the only time that you have any quiet time. Everyone is asleep. Make the first of 10 coffees that I'll consume that day. Sit on the couch. Turn the TV on. And I just see all of these young Australians-- thousands of them-- walking on the streets of Sydney, which is where I live, all of them looking like they could be friends of my oldest daughter.
我是一个起得很早的人。我大概五点半就起床了，我想很多妈妈都这样，因为这有时是你唯一能独享清静的时间。大家都还在睡觉。我冲了当天要喝的十杯咖啡里的第一杯。坐在沙发上，打开电视。我看到所有这些年轻的澳大利亚人——成千上万的人——走在悉尼的街头，也就是我住的地方，他们看起来都像是我大女儿的朋友。
It was a massive climate strike-- young people skipping school to protest, inspired by Greta Thunberg and her protests.
那是一场大规模的气候罢课——年轻人逃课抗议，灵感来自格蕾塔·通贝里和她的抗议活动。
And they were carrying all these signs, most of them handmade, saying, we can't vote. We don't have a lot of money. We don't have a lot of power, individually, or even as a group. Do something.
他们举着各种标语，大部分是手工制作的，上面写着：我们不能投票。我们没有多少钱。我们作为个人，甚至作为一个群体，都没有多少权力。做点什么吧。
She says it felt like they were pleading for action, their generation to hers. And the fact that they seemed exactly like her own children-- it just got to her in this way that was new.
她说，感觉他们是在恳求行动，是他们这一代向她这一代的恳求。而且他们看起来和她自己的孩子一模一样，这让她产生了一种前所未有的触动。
And I realized, actually, these kids are talking directly to me, specifically to me. It felt so personal. And I need to do something. And something in me shifted at that exact moment. And it felt physical. I felt an internal, physical sensation.
我意识到，其实这些孩子是在直接对我说话，专门对我说话。这种感觉非常个人化。我必须做点什么。就在那一刻，我内心深处有什么东西发生了改变。这是一种生理上的感受。我感觉到了一种内在的、身体上的震颤。
And even now, as I talk about it-- and I'm not a crier-- I actually well up with tears thinking about it because it was this genuine sense of, I can think about my kids and the things that I do for them every day. I make sure they brush their teeth, and I make sure they do their maths homework. And this is one of those things.
直到现在，当我谈论这件事时——我平时不怎么哭——我竟然会热泪盈眶，因为这是一种发自内心的感受，我可以想到我的孩子们，想到我每天为他们做的事情。我确保他们刷牙，确保他们做数学作业。这就像是这些琐事中的一件。
Suddenly, the fact that we've got a very limited period of time to turn this around-- the scientists talk about 10 years. They talk about 2030. So we've got the next decade. And in the next decade, my youngest kids won't yet have finished high school. And it just suddenly seemed so extraordinarily urgent, critically important.
突然间，我们应对气候变化的时间非常有限——科学家们谈论的是10年。他们说的是2030年。所以我们只有下一个十年。而在下一个十年里，我最小的孩子们甚至还没念完高中。这一切突然显得如此迫在眉睫，如此至关重要。
And I remember finishing my coffee, getting up off the couch. And I went straight to my study, and I logged into my-- you would describe it as a pension fund, but we call it superannuation. And within 10 minutes, I'd divested my superannuation completely away from fossil fuels.
我记得喝完咖啡，从沙发上站起来。我直接走进书房，登录了我的——你可能会称之为养老基金，但我们称之为“超级退休金”。不到10分钟，我就把我所有的退休金完全撤出了化石燃料行业。
And so that was one of hundreds of different things that I started to do from that point on, triggered by that moment.
那只是从那一刻起，我开始做的数百件不同事情中的一件，这一切都是由那个瞬间激发的。
Rebecca actually talked to one of our producers, Aviva DeKornfeld, who, in the last few months, has interviewed dozens of people who have had these wake-up moments. Hey, there, Aviva.
丽贝卡其实和我们的制片人阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德聊过，阿维娃在过去几个月里采访了数十位有过这种“觉醒时刻”的人。嘿，阿维娃。
Hey, Ira.
嘿，艾拉。
So these happen in all kinds of different ways, right?
所以这些事情以各种不同的方式发生，对吧？
Yeah. Yeah, to all kinds of different people, all of whom actually made a point to tell me they did not consider themselves environmentalists in any way prior to their wake-up moment.
是的。是的，发生在各种各样的人身上，他们所有人都特意告诉我，在那个觉醒时刻之前，他们根本不认为自己是环保主义者。
Oh, wow.
哦，天哪。
Yeah. It's more like they were just walking around and got bonked on the head, and then everything changed. People describe it like waking up in a bizarro world where everything is the same, but the way they feel about it is totally different. The wake-up reorganizes their priorities completely. In fact, lots of support groups have popped up in the past few years to help people deal with the immensity of these new feelings.
是的。更像是他们走着走着突然被重击了一下，然后一切都变了。人们形容那种感觉就像在奇异世界里醒来，一切看起来都没变，但他们对事物的感受却完全不同了。这种觉醒彻底重组了他们的优先级。事实上，过去几年出现了许多支持小组，帮助人们应对这些新涌现的巨大情绪。
What happened to Rebecca?
丽贝卡发生了什么？
In Rebecca's case, she totally changed the focus of her career, pivoted it to climate issues. She also cut back on eating meat, decided she needed to get an electric car or have no car. And those are the kind of things that would affect the rest of her family-- her husband and her kids. And what I found in these interviews is that this is where the trouble comes in for so many people-- when their families haven't undergone the same transformation that they have.
在丽贝卡的情况下，她完全改变了职业重心，转向了气候问题。她还减少了肉类摄入，决定买一辆电动汽车或者干脆不买车。而这些事情会影响她的家人们——她的丈夫和孩子们。我在这些采访中发现，这正是许多人陷入困境的地方——当他们的家人没有经历他们那样的转变时。
Right. That makes sense.
没错。这说得通。
Yeah. Everyone mentions some version of this. Like, this one guy, Glen Schleyer, I talked to-- after his wake-up moment, he tried to convince his whole family-- brothers, sisters, nieces, nephews-- to all see this the way that he now did and to come to climate rallies with him.
是的。每个人都提到了这种情况。比如我采访的格伦·施莱尔，在他觉醒之后，他试图说服他的整个家庭——兄弟、姐妹、侄子侄女——让他们都以他现在的方式看待问题，并和他一起去参加气候集会。
The common reaction that I got was, wow, I didn't know you were so passionate about this environmental stuff. Or, like, you're really into this. It's really interesting. It's great. It's great. I really support you. It's great that you're into this.
我得到的普遍反应是：“哇，我不知道你对这些环保的事情这么热衷。”或者像：“你真的很投入啊。真有意思。太棒了。太棒了。我真的很支持你。很高兴你对这个感兴趣。”
And that was so frustrating to me, because I'm like, I'm not into this. It's just what's happening. It's like, if there was a truck barreling toward us, and I was trying to get us out of the way, you wouldn't be like, wow, you're super passionate about trucks. I just didn't know you're so into trucks. Was this always a thing? I think it's really great that you have this interest. It's like, no, this is just what's happening.
这让我非常沮丧，因为我觉得，我不是“热衷”于此。这只是正在发生的事情。就像如果有一辆卡车正向我们冲过来，而我试图把大家拉开，你不会说：“哇，你对卡车真是超级热衷啊。我不知道你这么迷恋卡车。这一直是你的一项爱好吗？我觉得你很有趣。”不，这只是正在发生的事情。
So I was like, do you just keep running back and forth, yelling at people? Do you ruin your relationships? And I realized that I was potentially impacting relationships that are the most important thing to me in the world for no benefit.
所以我当时想，你是不是要一直跑来跑去，对着人们大吼大叫？你要毁掉你的人际关系吗？我意识到，我可能正在因为毫无成效的事情，而影响那些对我来说世界上最重要的人际关系。
No benefit because?
毫无成效是因为？
Because it wasn't changing anyone's mind. It wasn't working.
因为这并没有改变任何人的想法。这根本没用。
So Glen decided to leave his family alone. But other people told me that they couldn't back off in the same way, and it's had a huge impact on some of their closest relationships.
所以格伦决定不再强求他的家人。但其他人告诉我，他们无法像那样退缩，这对他们一些最亲密的关系产生了巨大的影响。
And that actually brings us to today's program. The idea for our show today came from Aviva's interest in these families where one person sees something that feels big and important and urgent, and they try to bring everybody along, and it is just bad for everyone. We have one story like that, plus a story about a surprisingly effective way to deal with the problems of the world, large and small. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
而这实际上引出了我们今天的节目。今天节目的灵感来自于阿维娃对这些家庭的兴趣：家庭中某个人看到了某些感觉很大、很重要、很紧急的事情，他们试图带动每个人一起行动，但这对每个人来说都很糟糕。我们有一个关于这样的故事，还有一个关于处理大大小小的世界性问题的出人意料的有效方法的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, 1.5 Degrees of Separation. So Aviva was interested in the toll that having a wake-up moment like this could have on a family. And she heard about somebody who had a moment like this over a decade ago. And it led him to quit his job, dedicate his life to activism. He tried to pull his family into it. And what unfolded was the most extreme example of things going badly in a family that Aviva heard of. It pretty much destroyed his family. He ended up estranged from them.
第一幕，《1.5度的分离》。所以阿维娃对经历这种觉醒时刻可能对家庭造成的代价很感兴趣。她听说有人在十多年前有过这样的时刻。这导致他辞掉工作，投身于激进主义。他试图拉着全家一起参与。结果发生的事是阿维娃听过的家庭中因观念不合而变糟的最极端的例子。这几乎摧毁了他的家庭。他最终与他们断绝了关系。
The guy is named Michael Foster. And when Aviva reached out and asked him if he would talk about how his climate activism had damaged his relationship with his wife and children, he was totally up for it. But he told Aviva that he thought his kids' side of the story was actually more important than his. He thought it was crucial that she talked to them, which, of course, Aviva wanted to do. Both children are now young adults. They were glad to talk.
那个人叫迈克尔·福斯特。当阿维娃联系他，询问他是否愿意谈论他的气候激进主义如何破坏了他与妻子和孩子的关系时，他欣然同意。但他告诉阿维娃，他认为他孩子们那一方的故事实际上比他的更重要。他认为她采访他们至关重要，当然，阿维娃也想这样做。两个孩子现在都是年轻人了。他们很乐意交谈。
What happened in their family is not necessarily typical of climate activists. Mike's activism shifted the whole center of gravity of their family in ways that are definitely particular to his personality. But the immense "end of the world" stakes of the issue were what sent Mike and his wife Malinda and their kids down the path they went. Here's Aviva.
他们家庭发生的事情并不一定典型于所有气候活动家。迈克的激进主义以某些完全属于他个人性格的方式改变了他们家庭的重心。但这个问题巨大的“世界末日”性质，正是将迈克和他的妻子马琳达以及他们的孩子们推向那条道路的原因。这是阿维娃带来的报道。
Mike and Malinda were never the kind of couple who saw eye-to-eye on the big stuff. They met when they were in high school in Texas. They both did speech and debate and would see one another at the competitions, though they weren't really friends. Mike, who was an evangelical Christian at the time, carried a Bible everywhere and led prayer circles before the tournaments, while Malinda and her friends would smoke weed out back.
迈克和马琳达从来都不是那种在重大问题上看法一致的夫妻。他们是在德克萨斯州上高中时认识的。他们都参加演讲和辩论，经常在比赛中见面，尽管他们并不是真正的朋友。迈克当时是一名福音派基督徒，走到哪里都带着圣经，并在比赛前领导祈祷小组，而马琳达和她的朋友们则躲在后面抽大麻。
His story is that the first time he really remembers meeting me was when he had just finished leading a prayer circle. And he met me. And I had a button. This was back when you wore buttons. And it said "not saved." And his mind just melted that someone would proudly wear a not-saved button.
他的版本是，他真正记得第一次见我是在他刚主持完一个祈祷小组之后。他遇见了我。当时我佩戴着一个徽章——那是人们还戴徽章的年代。上面写着“未得救”。他对于有人会如此自豪地佩戴着“未得救”徽章感到非常震惊，三观都崩塌了。
That's my story. How dare she tell my story. My mind melted. I didn't know that there were people out there who could just be happy and funny and saying, yeah, I'm not saved.
那是我的故事。她怎么敢讲我的故事。我的大脑确实在那一刻融化了。我不知道世界上还有人能如此快乐、有趣地承认：是的，我还没得救。
Each felt like the other was this kind of exotic bird or something-- totally foreign to them but also mesmerizing. And so when they went to the same college nearby, they started dating. Mike was no longer an evangelical Christian at that point. But Malinda says their relationship was still very rom-com, opposites attract.
每个人都觉得对方像某种异国情调的鸟类——对他来说完全陌生，但又令人着迷。所以当他们进入附近同一所大学时，他们开始约会。迈克当时已经不再是福音派基督徒了。但马琳达说他们的关系依然非常像浪漫喜剧，典型的“异性相吸”。
They broke up and got back together all throughout college and then found each other again in their late 20s. At that point, Mike was a child and family therapist, taking kids to the outdoors to do a kind of wilderness therapy. And Malinda had a corporate job, was making good money.
他们在大学期间分分合合，在快30岁时又走到了一起。当时，迈克是一名儿童和家庭治疗师，带孩子们去户外进行某种野外治疗。而马琳达有一份公司工作，收入丰厚。
So we were together for a few years. He had asked me to marry him a few times. And I was like, I don't think it's a good idea for us to get married. We're just too different.
我们在一起几年了。他向我求过几次婚。我说，我不觉得我们结婚是个好主意。我们实在太不同了。
But Mike felt familiar in a way that only first loves can. So eventually, Malinda said yes to Mike's proposal. They got married, had two kids, Emrys and Stella, lived in Seattle. At this point, climate change wasn't a big part of their lives beyond the basic stuff.
但迈克有一种只有初恋才会有的熟悉感。所以最终，马琳达答应了迈克的求婚。他们结婚了，有了两个孩子，埃姆里斯和斯特拉，住在西雅图。那时，气候变化在他们的生活中并不算太大的事情，仅限于基本层面。
We were really green. We were your cartoon green Seattle family. So whatever stereotype you have, that was what we were doing. [CHUCKLES]
我们当时真的很环保。我们就是你卡通片里那种典型的西雅图环保家庭。所以无论你有什么样的刻板印象，我们当时做的就是那些。 [轻笑]
They recycled, composted. They used energy-efficient light bulbs. And then one day, Mike heard about this new documentary he wanted to go see--
他们回收垃圾、堆肥。他们使用节能灯泡。直到有一天，迈克听说了一部他想去看的纪录片——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I am Al Gore. I used to be the next president of the United States of America.
我是阿尔·戈尔。我曾是下一任美国总统。
[LAUGHTER, CHEERING]
[笑声、欢呼声]
--An Inconvenient Truth. Mike convinced Malinda to go see it with him for their date night. Sitting there in the dark, Mike felt like Al Gore had taken all the dots of information about climate change that Mike had picked up over the past couple decades and arranged them into a pointillist painting of our future. And the picture was grimmer and more dramatic than he thought.
——《难以忽视的真相》。迈克说服马琳达在约会之夜去看了这部片子。坐在黑暗中，迈克感觉阿尔·戈尔把他过去几十年来零星收集到的关于气候变化的信息点，拼凑成了一幅关于我们未来的点彩画。这幅画比他想象的还要阴郁、还要戏剧化。
And then at the end of it, it has the credits roll. And during the credits, it will, on this black screen, have these little white letters that say things like, plant a tree. Change your light bulbs. Drive less. And that's it, right? So you've just spent an hour and a half learning that the world is ending, and nobody is doing anything, and you're supposed to plant a tree. So there was this major, major disconnect of, wait a minute. That's not going to do it. That's not even close.
影片最后，字幕开始滚动。在滚动过程中，黑色的屏幕上会出现一些白色的小字，写着诸如“种棵树”、“换节能灯”、“少开车”之类的建议。就这样，对吧？你花了一个半小时了解世界即将毁灭，而没有人采取任何行动，结果你被告知应该去种棵树。所以这里出现了一个巨大的断层：等等，那根本没用。连边都沾不上。
Before the documentary, Mike thought we had time. Now it seemed clear to him we were just a few decades away from a radically different planet. Mike started poring over climate research, reading every day. He traveled to California to go to a training led by Al Gore himself, where he learned to give a slideshow about climate change.
纪录片之前，迈克认为我们还有时间。现在，在他看来，我们离一个彻底改变的星球只有几十年之遥。迈克开始钻研气候研究，每天阅读。他前往加利福尼亚参加由阿尔·戈尔本人主持的培训，在那里他学会了如何演示关于气候变化的幻灯片。
When he came back from the training, Mike showed his kids the slideshow and presented it at their schools. Emrys, Mike's older kid, who, by the way, uses the pronouns they/them, remembers being excited by that. And this was in 2012. Emrys was 10 at the time.
从培训回来后，迈克向他的孩子们展示了幻灯片，并在他们的学校进行了演示。埃姆里斯，迈克的大孩子——顺便说一下，埃姆里斯使用“他们/他们”作为代词——记得当时很兴奋。那是2012年，埃姆里斯当时10岁。
It felt like minor celebrity status, right? Because my dad was a guest speaker. And I needed everyone to know that that was my dad. It's like, you know the presentation we're having today? Yeah, my dad is doing that. Or, like, I heard that my dad is going to be coming next week to do a presentation in class.
感觉就像有了小明星的地位，对吧？因为我爸爸是特邀演讲嘉宾。我需要每个人都知道那是我的爸爸。就像：你知道我们今天有个演讲吗？是的，我爸在讲那个。或者：我听说我爸下周要来班里做演讲。
Mike and his kids start climate clubs at their schools. Mike also teaches Emrys and Stella the slideshow, and they all start going around to teach it together. Both kids threw themselves into the work. For Emrys, the importance of the topic immediately resonated. But Stella, who's eight, had a much simpler reason.
迈克和他的孩子们在学校成立了气候俱乐部。迈克还教埃姆里斯和斯特拉那个幻灯片，他们开始一起到处去做演示。两个孩子都全身心地投入到这项工作中。对埃姆里斯来说，这个话题的重要性引起了直接的共鸣。但斯特拉当时8岁，理由简单得多。
It was a way for me to get his attention. If I asked a question, he would be paying attention to just me rather than the family, which I guess is selfish. But at the time, I was like, Dad, look over here. I can ask questions about climate change. I'm smart.
这是我吸引他注意力的一种方式。如果我问问题，他就会专注于我，而不是专注于整个家庭，我想这有点自私。但在当时，我想的是：爸爸，看这边。我能问关于气候变化的问题。我很聪明。
News of Mike's slideshow spread, and he started being invited to present at other schools. Pretty early on, Mike decided that kids were the answer. His activism would focus on them. That was already his specialty as a therapist. And he figured, children have the most at stake here. They're open to the message. And adults will be able to hear the science from them differently than they'll hear it from other adults.
迈克演示幻灯片的消息传开了，他开始受邀到其他学校演讲。很早之前，迈克就认定孩子们是答案。他的激进活动将聚焦于他们。作为一名治疗师，这已经是他的专长了。而且他认为，孩子们在这里利害关系最大。他们对这个信息持开放态度。成年人从他们那里听到科学，会与从其他成年人那里听到时有不同的感受。
So Mike's first big step down that path-- he organized a march with a national kid-centered climate group called I Matter. He says the Seattle police gave the marchers a 14-motorcycle escort to Pike Place Market. Emrys and Stella both spoke at the march. Emrys said they'd never talked in front of so many people before.
所以迈克的第一次重大尝试——他组织了一场名为“我介意（I Matter）”的全国性儿童气候组织游行。他说西雅图警方给游行队伍提供了14辆摩托车的护送，一直到派克市场。埃姆里斯和斯特拉都在游行中发表了演讲。埃姆里斯说他们以前从未在这么多人面前说过话。
He helped me write my speech, and he had me practice it a ton. I was super excited to speak there because everybody's attention was on me.
他帮我写了演讲稿，还让我反复练习。我非常兴奋能在那儿发言，因为大家的注意力都在我身上。
Stella, the younger one, found all the attention a little overwhelming.
斯特拉，小一点的那个，觉得所有的关注让她有点难以承受。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Stella!
斯特拉！
The main thing I remember was looking at my dad to focus my gaze.
我记得最清楚的是，看着爸爸来聚焦我的目光。
To steady you.
为了让你镇定下来。
Yeah. And I really looked at him to not freak out.
是的。我真的通过注视他来防止自己惊慌失措。
In this speech and all the ones after it, Emrys says that Mike gave each of them specific roles to fill, roles that Emrys says they naturally fit into.
在这次演讲和之后的所有演讲中，埃姆里斯说，迈克给他们每人分配了特定的角色，埃姆里斯说这些角色他们天生就很契合。
Stella was the one that would make the audience go, oh my gosh. She's so cute.
斯特拉就是那种会让观众觉得“哦，天哪，她真可爱”的角色。
Hi. I'm Stella Foster, and I'm nine years old.
嗨，我是斯特拉·福斯特，我9岁了。
And then I was the one who was supposed to make the audience go, like, oh, OK. Wow. [CHUCKLES]
然后我就是那种应该让观众觉得“哦，好的，哇”的角色。 [轻笑]
It was like a one-two punch. Like, Stella disarmed them, and then you went in for the kill.
这就像组合拳。斯特拉先解除了他们的防备，然后你再进行致命一击。
Yeah. [CHUCKLES] Basically, yeah. I think I was a little bit supposed to scare people.
是的。 [轻笑] 基本上是这样。我想我稍微有点被要求去吓唬人们。
We just need the adults to get their acts together and realize that each year they wait is 30 more years of floods, fires, droughts, famines, and extinctions.
我们需要成年人振作起来，意识到他们等待的每一年，都意味着多出30年的洪水、火灾、干旱、饥荒和物种灭绝。
For Malinda, watching Mike and the kids give speeches and spend so much time together-- it was really nice. They're having fun and working on something that felt so important. She wasn't around much to help. She had a big job at a telecommunications company that kept her busy and on the road a lot of the time. But she jumped in where she could. She made a website for Mike and did a lot of the behind-the-scenes logistics stuff she's good at.
对于马琳达来说，看着迈克和孩子们演讲并花这么多时间在一起，真的很美好。他们玩得很开心，在做一件感觉如此重要的事情。她没怎么参与帮忙。她在一家电信公司有一份大工作，经常忙得团团转。但她尽其所能提供帮助。她为迈克做了一个网站，并处理了许多她擅长的幕后后勤工作。
Mike got more ambitious and brought the kids along. They started organizing for Plant-for-the-Planet, a kid-run organization with a goal of planting a trillion trees. The whole family recruited friends to join. Mike quit his job to focus on climate work. Emrys and Stella met the governor and the mayor. They were lead plaintiffs in a lawsuit against the state of Washington to curb emissions. They were in an HBO documentary about kid climate activists. But none of that stuff felt like enough to Mike. He was thinking more about the way he and the family were living at home.
迈克变得更有雄心了，并带上了孩子们。他们开始为“为地球植树（Plant-for-the-Planet）”组织工作，这是一个由儿童运营、目标是种植一万亿棵树的组织。全家都招募朋友加入。迈克辞掉了工作，专注于气候工作。埃姆里斯和斯特拉见到了州长和市长。他们是一场针对华盛顿州限制排放诉讼的主要原告。他们还出现在一部关于儿童气候活动家的HBO纪录片中。但所有这些在迈克看来都不够。他更多地思考着他和家人的居家生活方式。
Malinda and I had an agreement. I was the vegetarian. I was the one doing the "make the world better" stuff. And she was the one who was working at the corporate giant, paying the bills. And I was fine with that. But when I'm doing these climate talks-- and I mean, like, one day would be five talks-- and I'm hearing myself going over this material and really grasping at what I'm saying, it became harder for me to be OK with the trip to Hawaii.
马琳达和我有个协议。我是素食主义者。我是那个做“让世界更美好”事情的人。而她是那个在企业巨头工作、支付账单的人。我对此没意见。但当我在做这些气候讲座时——我是说，有时候一天五场讲座——我听着自己一遍遍重复这些材料，真正理解我所说的一切时，再接受去夏威夷的旅行就变得更难了。
Harder for Mike to be OK because airplanes emit so much carbon dioxide.
迈克觉得难接受，是因为飞机排放大量的二氧化碳。
So I went out on a limb. And I was like, this has no integrity for me anymore. I can't just go along with our agreement.
所以我孤注一掷。我说，这对我的诚信而言已不复存在了。我不能再维持我们的协议了。
Other people I talked to who went through a wake-up moment-- they also got to this point. They came to believe that we have to change our behavior in all kinds of ways to avoid the worst-case scenarios. And we have to do that knowing individual action won't be enough. One family driving an electric car or giving up plastic straws isn't going to do the job. Any serious climate solution will require an overhaul of our energy sources at a global level. But it'll also require us to live differently. Without that, the situation won't change. And that's where things get messy-- deciding where to draw the line in your own family.
我采访过的其他经历过觉醒时刻的人——他们也达到了这一点。他们开始相信，为了避免最坏的情况，我们必须以各种方式改变我们的行为。而且我们必须意识到，个人行动是不够的。一个家庭驾驶电动汽车或放弃塑料吸管并不能解决问题。任何认真的气候解决方案都需要在全球范围内全面改革我们的能源结构。但这也要求我们改变生活方式。没有这一点，情况就不会改变。而这正是问题变得混乱的地方——决定在你的家庭中划定界限。
The kids really wanted to get a cat. And I was like, well, I grew up with pets. I think that'd be great. And he said, no, we can't do that. And I'm trying to understand why. He says, the carbon footprint of a domesticated house pet are ridiculous.
孩子们真的很想养只猫。我说，嗯，我从小养宠物。我觉得那太棒了。他说，不，我们不能那样做。我试着去理解原因。他说，家养宠物的碳足迹非常惊人。
That is, all the processed meat the pets eat, and the cans and plastic the food comes in, plus cat litter, dog toys, trips to the vet.
也就是说，宠物吃的所有加工肉类，以及食物包装的罐头和塑料，还有猫砂、狗玩具、看兽医的费用。
We're not going to support that. There cannot be pets in this house.
我们不能支持那个。这家里不能养宠物。
The family ended up settling on getting chickens, which turned out to be a good compromise because the kids loved the chickens. And Mike was happy the chickens produced eggs, because it meant they wouldn't be supporting factory farms that produce supermarket eggs. But flying on planes became a real point of contention in the family. Malinda wanted to take the kids to Disney World for vacation.
这个家庭最终决定养鸡，这结果是一个不错的妥协，因为孩子们很喜欢鸡。迈克也对鸡产蛋感到高兴，因为这意味着他们不用支持生产超市鸡蛋的工厂化农场。但坐飞机成为了家庭中真正的矛盾点。马琳达想带孩子们去迪士尼世界度假。
He's like, we're not going. We're not? He's like, no, we're never getting on a plane again. We're not? I missed that memo. What? What? And I made the mistake of saying, but I fly for work. And he was like, exactly. And maybe if you didn't fly, the world would be a better place.
他说，我们不去。我们不去？他说，不，我们再也不会坐飞机了。我们不去？我错过那个备忘录了吗？什么？什么？我犯了一个错误，说，但我为了工作要坐飞机。他就像：没错。也许如果你不坐飞机，世界会变得更好。
To Mike, flying felt like an existential threat to his kids' futures and to everyone's.
对迈克来说，飞行就像是对他孩子未来以及每个人未来的生存威胁。
It was unbearable for me to continue doing the things that were going to make their life impossible-- actually impossible-- in the near future.
继续做那些会让他们的生活在不久的将来变得不可能——真正意义上的不可能——的事情，对我来说是难以忍受的。
At the time, did you have any doubts about the lifestyle changes you were making? Because you're having to balance really believing in the cause and also accepting that you're a dad with two kids. And maybe one pet doesn't actually make that big of a difference in the grand scheme of things, but it does make a really big difference in my kids' lives. How did you balance that?
当时，你对自己正在进行的这些生活方式的改变有任何怀疑吗？因为你必须在真正相信这一事业和接受你是一位有两个孩子的父亲之间取得平衡。也许一只宠物在宏观方案中实际上并没有那么大的区别，但它对我的孩子们的生活确实有很大的影响。你是如何平衡的？
That was really impossible to balance because I'm not talking about a cause, because I'm talking about their survival and the things they're going to suffer when they get older. So anyway, so I'm sorry. I'm getting into the preaching mode, and we're trying to talk family here. But to me, it's the same thing.
那真的不可能平衡，因为我谈论的不是一项事业，而是在谈论他们的生存，以及他们长大后将要遭受的苦难。总之，抱歉。我进入说教模式了，而我们是在谈论家庭。但在我看来，这是一回事。
So Malinda kept flying for work, but nobody else flew. And Malinda didn't like all these changes. But she didn't disagree, exactly.
所以马琳达为了工作继续飞行，但其他人都不飞。马琳达不喜欢这些改变。但她并没有完全不同意。
Climate change is a noble cause. That was what I was telling myself. This is for the world. This is for a better future for my children and their children. Why am I being such a bitch about it?
气候变化是一项崇高的事业。我当时就是这么告诉自己的。这是为了世界。这是为了我的孩子和他们孩子的未来。我为什么要在这件事上表现得像个泼妇呢？
One of the biggest ways climate activism changed this family is that it turned Mike into a kind of stage dad, performing with his kids all the time, with all the tension and friction that comes with that. It was especially intense because Mike's climate work was all about kids, so he needed his kids to be the face of it. Here's Emrys.
气候激进主义改变这个家庭最大的方式之一，就是把迈克变成了一种“舞台父亲”，一直和孩子们一起表演，伴随着所有的压力和摩擦。这尤其激烈，因为迈克的气候工作全都是关于孩子的，所以他需要他的孩子成为门面。这是埃姆里斯。
I started having issues with my dad when it was-- he started feeling more like a coach than a dad. And he was just bringing more and more and more things. It's like, I would wake up in the morning, and he would be like, we're leaving in two hours. There's a presentation. Here's your notes. You have to speak. Write a speech now.
我开始和我爸爸产生问题了，当他开始觉得更像个教练而不是父亲的时候。他带来的东西越来越多。就像：我早上醒来，他会说：我们两小时后出发。有个演讲。这是你的笔记。你必须发言。现在写演讲稿。
Emrys had always liked giving speeches, liked writing them. But Mike wanted to see their speeches ahead of time and practice, and would get angry if they didn't let him, and get mad afterwards if he thought they didn't hit the right points. In front of crowds, Mike was always complimentary of their speeches.
埃姆里斯一直喜欢演讲，喜欢写演讲稿。但迈克想要提前看他们的演讲稿并练习，如果他们不给看，他就会生气，如果他觉得他们没有讲到点子上，事后也会发火。在人群面前，迈克总是赞美他们的演讲。
It's like, if you're in a theater production, and the director gives a talk after the show or something. I was the actor. I played my little part. And then he would come out and be like, oh, I'm so proud. They did an amazing job.
就像，如果你在剧院演出，演出结束后导演发表讲话一样。我是演员。我扮演了我的小角色。然后他会出来说：哦，我很骄傲。他们做得太棒了。
My name is Michael Foster, and I am a proud papa right now.
我是迈克尔·福斯特，我现在是一位骄傲的爸爸。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
I don't know what to say. They blow me away every single time.
我不知道该说什么。他们每次都让我惊艳。
And then once the audience leaves, it's time for notes. Once they're not looking, then you talk about what you did wrong and everything that you have to do better next time, to put it politely.
然后观众一离开，就是记笔记的时间。一旦他们不看，你就得谈论你做错了什么，以及你下次必须做好的每一件事，说得文雅一点的话。
Since Malinda was off working so much at the time, supporting the family, she had no real sense that, increasingly, this had become Emrys and Mike's dynamic until, one day, the kids had a speech far outside of town. Malinda drove the family to and from the speech since she had a hybrid car, and Mike's electric car couldn't make it that far.
由于马琳达当时经常在外奔波工作、支撑家庭，她并不知道这种情况已经逐渐变成了埃姆里斯和迈克的动态，直到有一天，孩子们在城外有一个演讲。马琳达开车送全家去参加演讲，因为她开的是混合动力车，迈克的电动车没法开那么远。
Emrys had given a speech. And I thought it was brilliant. I'm the mom. And we got in the car, and I was driving. And Mike was in the seat next to me, and the kids were in the back. And he was yelling because Emrys hadn't let him read the speech before they gave it.
埃姆里斯发表了演讲。我觉得这很精彩。我是妈妈。我们上了车，我开车。迈克坐在我旁边的座位上，孩子们在后座。他一直在咆哮，因为埃姆里斯在演讲前没让他看演讲稿。
And he was saying, you should have let me read that speech before, because I would have told you at the time. I would have told you that you were missing these points. And goddammit. If you had let me see that, you would have done a better job. You missed your opportunity. You fucked it up, and you missed your opportunity. And I'm driving, going, whoa. So let me just say, I thought it was great. Well, what do you know? You don't even listen half the time. And I was like, whoa.
他说：你应该让你看那篇演讲稿的，因为我会当时就告诉你的。我会告诉你你漏掉了这些重点。该死的。如果你让我看了，你本来会做得更好的。你错过了你的机会。你搞砸了，你错过了你的机会。我开着车，心想：哇。让我说一句，我觉得这很棒。哦，你知道什么？你甚至有一半时间都不听。我心想：哇。
Looking back, Malinda points to this moment as one of her failures, that she let her kids give speeches after this. But at the time, Mike was so confident in what was right. And Malinda didn't trust the feeling that told her otherwise.
如今回想起来，马琳达把这个时刻视为她的失败之一，她让孩子们在那之后继续演讲。但在当时，迈克对什么是正确的充满信心。马琳达不信任告诉她事实的直觉。
So I'd-- like, well, maybe this is their dynamic. Maybe this is how they communicate, that they flare up, and they-- not that the kids ever yelled, but maybe Mike yells. But maybe that's how it works, because the next day, they're working on it again.
所以我当时想：嗯，也许这就是他们的动态。也许这就是他们交流的方式，他们会爆发，他们会——并不是说孩子们吼过，但也许迈克吼了。但也许这就是运作方式，因为第二天他们又在为此工作了。
And he's a family therapist, or child therapist.
而且他是一名家庭治疗师，或者儿童治疗师。
And he's a child and family therapist. So there's that hanging over my head, too, of, he knows. He's the expert.
而且他是一名儿童和家庭治疗师。所以这也悬在我的心头，因为他是专家。
This is just the beginning of their family breaking apart. And one of the reasons Mike was eager to speak with me is because he feels pretty in the dark about what happened, what split his family up and left his kids so bitter that, at this point, they haven't spoken to him in years. He doesn't get what he could have done that was so bad his family still wants nothing to do with him. He said he feels like he's in an Agatha Christie novel. He knows he's the killer. He just has no idea how he did it.
这只是他们家庭分崩离析的开始。迈克渴望与我交谈的原因之一是，他对发生的事情、是什么拆散了他的家庭并让他的孩子们如此痛苦感到困惑，以至于直到现在，他们已经多年没和他说过话了。他不明白自己究竟做了什么糟糕的事，以至于他的家庭至今不想和他有任何往来。他说他感觉自己就像在阿加莎·克里斯蒂的小说里。他知道自己是凶手。只是他完全不知道自己是怎么做到的。
When we spoke, Mike never contested anyone's memories of what went down. He told me, if they said it, I believe it. He knows he has a temper. Malinda said he's always had one. In college, he'd have blow-ups, though she always knew how to calm him down. But Mike and Malinda and the kids all agree-- the outbursts ramped up considerably after Mike got into climate activism. Malinda said he was never physically violent with her or the kids. But the frequency and the focus of the blow-ups changed.
当我们交谈时，迈克从未反驳任何人对发生之事的记忆。他告诉我：如果他们这么说，我相信。他知道自己有脾气。马琳达说他一直都有。在大学里，他会有爆发的时候，尽管她总知道如何让他冷静下来。但迈克、马琳达和孩子们都同意——迈克投身气候激进主义后，爆发频率大大增加。马琳达说他从未对她或孩子们进行过身体暴力。但爆发的频率和焦点改变了。
I would just go from, like, 0 to 90, and you would not see it coming. And all of a sudden, it was like, inside me, it felt like, OK, the world is going to end because of this, [CHUCKLES] right?
我只会从0到90，你根本预料不到。突然之间，我内心感觉：好的，世界要因为这个终结了， [轻笑] 对吧？
Because climate?
因为气候？
Because of something somebody did or said or whatever. Like, if we can't-- if our family, or you and me, can't do this one simple thing, then how does the world get to remain living, right? Because we're--
因为某人做的事或说的话或其他什么。就像，如果我们不能——如果我们的家庭，或者你和我，不能做这一件简单的事，那世界怎么还能继续存在？因为我们——
The stakes always felt that high.
利害关系总是感觉那么高。
Yeah. Sometimes it would just be like, OK, we-- I am this person who's in this role, trying to say, here's how we get to live on Earth for the next 10,000 years. And I can't persuade my family to let go of the Starbucks cup or whatever the thing was at the moment. OK, so then the world ends.
是的。有时就像：好的，我们——我是这个角色中的人，试图说：这就是我们未来一万年如何在地球上生活的方法。但我不能说服我的家人放下星巴克杯子，或者那一刻不管是别的什么东西。好的，那么世界末日了。
That's what it actually felt like to you.
这就是你真实的感觉。
Yeah.
是的。
More than once, Mike called Stella a fucking bitch and a cunt. Stella said before Mike got into climate activism, he would yell at her about the kind of stuff any parent might-- for lying about brushing her teeth or staying up late past bedtime. But in those instances, Stella knew her dad still loved her. Now, she worried about that.
迈克不止一次称斯特拉为“该死的泼妇”和“婊子”。斯特拉说，在迈克投身气候激进主义之前，他也会因为任何家长可能会做的事对她吼叫——比如撒谎没刷牙或者熬夜太晚。但在那些情况下，斯特拉知道爸爸仍然爱她。现在，她对此感到担忧。
I had a good father for years before the climate change started. There were flaws. But it was only once it was climate change, where he put so much of himself into it and wanted me to put so much of myself into it, that I really got the feeling that his love was completely conditional.
在气候变化开始之前，我有一个很好的父亲，持续了好多年。尽管有瑕疵。但只有在气候变化这件事上，当他投入了这么多自我，并希望我也投入这么多自我时，我才真正感觉到他的爱是完全有条件的。
Stella remembers when she realized she was over climate activism. It was her nine and a half birthday. They celebrate half birthdays in their family. And in celebration, they'd planned a dinner at one of Stella's favorite restaurants. But before they left the house, something happened to set Mike off, and he started ranting about the state of the world. Stella said that when her dad got into climate-talk mode, there was nothing to do but listen. 15 minutes ticked by, then 30, then 45.
斯特拉记得她意识到自己不再支持气候激进主义的那一刻。那是她九岁半的生日。他们家庭有庆祝半岁生日的习惯。为了庆祝，他们计划在斯特拉最喜欢的餐厅之一吃晚餐。但在离开家之前，发生了一些事让迈克爆发了，他开始抨击世界的现状。斯特拉说，当爸爸进入“气候谈话模式”时，除了听着别无他法。15分钟过去了，接着是30分钟，然后是45分钟。
I just remember thinking, like, I just want to talk about what we did at school today. I want to talk about this cat I saw on the walk home. I want to talk on my half birthday-- and feeling like it was not an option for me to talk, because he was talking.
我只记得我当时心想：我只想聊聊今天学校做了什么。我想聊聊回家的路上我看到的那只猫。我想在我半岁生日时聊点别的——但我觉得我没选择权，因为他一直在说。
Stella never told anyone she wanted to quit activism, because deep down, she felt like she had this personal responsibility to stop climate change. Secretly, Emrys was feeling the same way.
斯特拉从未告诉任何人她想退出激进活动，因为在内心深处，她觉得阻止气候变化是她个人的责任。私下里，埃姆里斯也有同样的感觉。
The more I started realizing that I didn't want to do it, the worse a person I was. Like, horrible things are going to happen to people because I'm not willing to do this. It felt like I was the worst person in the world. It was all guilt all the time, and fear. It was fear of him and fear of the apocalypse.
我越开始意识到我不想做这些，就越觉得自己是个坏人。就像，糟糕的事情将会发生，因为我不愿意做这个。感觉我成了世界上最坏的人。到处都是内疚，一直都是，还有恐惧。是对他的恐惧，也是对世界末日的恐惧。
Stella's carbon footprint started to haunt her. When her mom drove her to school, when she drank a glass of milk, even when she exhaled sometimes, she'd think, all I'm doing is putting more carbon dioxide into the air. She started having nightmares every night of the world burning, or of oceans rising and flooding her house, or going to the grocery store and finding the shelves completely bare because droughts had killed off all the plants.
斯特拉的碳足迹开始困扰她。当妈妈开车送她去学校时，当她喝牛奶时，甚至有时当她呼气时，她都会想：我所做的一切只是在往空气中排放更多的二氧化碳。她开始每天晚上做恶梦，梦见世界燃烧，或者海洋上升淹没了房子，或者去杂货店发现货架完全空了，因为干旱杀死了所有的植物。
Mike and Malinda both told me they had no idea the kids were feeling this way at the time, which Emrys and Stella said makes sense. They were good at hiding it. When I asked Mike about how bad the kids felt, he said he never meant to make his kids feel as bad as they did. But he also defended guilt as a tactic.
迈克和马琳达都告诉我，当时他们根本不知道孩子们有这种感觉，埃姆里斯和斯特拉说这说得通。他们很擅长隐藏。当我问迈克孩子们感觉有多糟糕时，他说他从没想过让孩子们感觉那么糟糕。但他也为“内疚”作为一种策略进行了辩护。
Guilt is seriously underrated. Guilt and shame keep people from murdering each other. And honestly, guilt may be one of the few things that could keep life on Earth going for the next 10,000 years. If we can't feel guilt or shame about what we're doing and learn how to do something else, it was over a long time ago.
内疚被严重低估了。内疚和羞耻感阻止人们互相残杀。坦白说，内疚可能是让地球在未来一万年继续生存下去的少数几件事之一。如果我们不能对自己正在做的事情感到内疚或羞耻，并学习做点别的事情，那很久以前就完了。
One way to hear this story is that it's not about climate change but about a dad who goes off the deep end for reasons that have more to do with his own personality than anything else. But I can't dismiss the role climate change plays in this story. I think the grim picture of the future that Mike carries in his head is actually more accurate than the picture most of us carry around.
听这个故事的一种方式是，它无关气候变化，而关乎一个父亲因与其性格有关的原因而非其他任何原因而走火入魔。但我不能忽略气候变化在这个故事中扮演的角色。我认为迈克脑海中勾勒出的严峻未来，实际上比我们大多数人脑中勾勒的要准确得多。
And it's genuinely hard to figure out the right way to have feelings about climate change. It's easy to lose perspective when the problem is so vast and woven into every part of how we live, how we get to work, what we eat, and the stakes are so high.
而且，要找到对气候变化产生感受的正确方式确实很难。当问题如此巨大并交织在我们生活的每一个部分——我们如何上班、吃什么、而且利害关系如此之高时，很容易失去视角。
I talked to other people who had wake-up moments, many of whom are reasonable and kind and not alarmist by nature, who alienated their families, and in lots of cases, lost their families, in the wake of their newfound clarity. Malinda and the kids see all that but also believe it didn't have to go this way. Malinda said that to me in our very first conversation. Mike could have done his climate work without torturing his family. That is, he didn't need to cuss out his kids.
我采访了其他经历过觉醒时刻的人，他们中许多人理性、善良，天生不是危言耸听者，但他们在重获清晰认知后疏远了家人，在许多情况下，失去了家人。马琳达和孩子们看到了这一切，但也相信事情不一定要发展成这样。马琳达在我们的第一次谈话中就这样对我说了。迈克本可以在不折磨家人的情况下进行他的气候工作。也就是说，他不需要辱骂他的孩子们。
Coming up, how the most ambitious, arguably most successful thing you ever do as a political activist could also be the worst thing that you do for your family. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，作为一名政治活动家，你能做出的最雄心勃勃、可以说最成功的事情，怎么也可能是你对家庭做过的最糟糕的事情。稍后揭晓，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- "The End of the World As We Know It." If you're just tuning in, we're in the middle of Aviva DeKornfeld's story about Mike Foster and his family and how his climate activism led to changes in their family and ultimately divorce and his estrangement from his two kids who he hasn't spoken with in years. We will pick up where we left off. Both of his kids, Stella and Emrys, want to quit doing activism with their dad. Again, here's Aviva.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“我们所知的世界末日”。如果你刚收听，我们正在讲阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德关于迈克·福斯特和他的家庭的故事，以及他的气候激进主义如何导致他们家庭的变化，并最终导致离婚以及他与两个孩子疏远，他已经多年没和他们说过话了。我们将接着刚才的地方继续讲。他的两个孩子，斯特拉和埃姆里斯，想要退出与父亲一起从事激进活动。再次请出阿维娃。
It takes about two years of going to climate meetings and speaking at rallies with their dad before Stella and Emrys confided in each other about how they really felt about it and what they actually wanted. Here's Emrys.
在斯特拉和埃姆里斯向对方倾诉他们的真实感受以及他们真正想要什么之前，他们跟着父亲去参加气候会议并在集会上发言大约持续了两年。这是埃姆里斯。
I remember we were out on the back porch going inside, and Stella stopped me. And she whispered, do you think Mom and Dad are going to get a divorce? And I was like, I don't know, but I kind of hope so. And she was like, me, too. And yeah, after that, it was better because we had that solidarity.
我记得我们当时在后门廊准备进屋，斯特拉拦住了我。她悄悄问：你觉得爸爸妈妈会离婚吗？我说：我不知道，但我有点希望他们离婚。她说：我也是。是的，在那之后，事情好转了一些，因为我们有了这种团结。
Stella started doing secret research about parental custody to figure out the odds that she and Emrys would get to live with their mom in the event that her parents did get divorced. And she started dropping hints. She was just beginning sixth grade around this time, and her school offered these elective support groups. There were a bunch of different options, and one of the groups was for kids with divorced parents. That was a group Stella signed up for. When Malinda found out which group Stella had joined and asked her about it, Stella shrugged and said, just in case.
斯特拉开始秘密研究父母监护权，想弄清楚如果父母离婚，她和埃姆里斯能和妈妈住在一起的几率。她开始暗示。当时她刚开始上六年级，学校提供了一些选修支持小组。有很多不同的选择，其中一个是针对离异家庭孩子的小组。斯特拉报了名。当马琳达发现斯特拉加入了哪个小组并询问她时，斯特拉耸耸肩说：以防万一。
Things continued like this for a while-- everyone going through the motions-- until it all came to a head one night. Emrys wanted to go to a Fall Out Boy concert. Mike insisted they come to the monthly Plant-for-the-Planet meeting instead. When the meeting was over, Emrys and Stella waited by the car for 45 minutes in the cold before he came out.
情况就这样持续了一段时间——每个人都在例行公事——直到有一天晚上事情发展到了顶峰。埃姆里斯想去看“打倒男孩（Fall Out Boy）”乐队的演唱会。迈克坚持让他们去参加当月的“为地球植树”会议。会议结束后，埃姆里斯和斯特拉在寒风中守在车边等了45分钟，他才出来。
We started driving home. I think I was very obviously sulking. And ultimately, I told him that I was annoyed that he had taken so long to come back and that I hadn't really wanted to go to the meeting in the first place. And he just lost it. He got so mad.
我们开始开车回家。我想我当时表现得非常明显地在生闷气。最终，我告诉他，我对他回来花这么长时间感到恼火，而且我本来就不想去参加那个会议。他突然就失控了。他气坏了。
Stella remembers this night, too.
斯特拉也记得那个晚上。
He was shouting in this car, just yelling, like, you're ungrateful. You don't realize how much I do for you. Why can't you just go along with it for one night? What is your problem? What is so important about this fucking concert? And he was driving erratically. He would pull the car over super fast and turn and start yelling at us again, unprompted.
他在车里大吼大叫，一直在喊：你真是不知好歹。你根本不知道我为你做了多少。为什么你就不能顺从一次，哪怕一个晚上？你有什么毛病？这个该死的演唱会到底有什么重要的？而且他开车乱来。他会超快地把车靠边停下，转过头来，毫无征兆地又开始对我们大吼大叫。
And what are you guys doing at that point?
那时候你们在做什么？
We are literally-- both of us are just sitting in the back seat, mouths closed, eyes wide, crying, absolutely terrified. I'd never seen him that angry, and I'd seen him get angry a lot. And so yeah, when we came home, we just got out of the car as fast as we possibly could and ran inside to get to our mom, because it was like the safe zone in a game of tag or something. It was like, she meant protection from him.
我们真的是——我们俩就坐在后座，闭着嘴，瞪大眼睛，哭着，完全吓坏了。我从未见过他那么生气，尽管我经常看到他发火。所以是的，当我们回到家时，我们尽可能快地跑出车，跑进屋去找妈妈，因为就像捉人游戏里的安全区一样。就好像，她意味着躲避他的保护。
I was in the family room, and the door flew open. The kids came running in, crying, sobbing. And their dad came running in after them, screaming at the top of his lungs. And I'm like, whoa, whoa, whoa. What is happening here? What is going on? And I went upstairs to talk to the kids. And they said they were afraid that they were going to die in the car. I'm like, what the hell happened?
我在家庭活动室，门突然被推开了。孩子们哭着跑了进来，泣不成声。他们的父亲在后面追着，声嘶力竭地尖叫。我说：哇，哇，哇。这是怎么了？发生了什么事？我上楼去和孩子们谈话。他们说他们害怕在车里会死掉。我说：到底发生了什么鬼事？
Malinda made up her mind. Not long after that night, she told Mike she wanted a divorce. Mike calls it a climate divorce. Malinda says no. If anything, climate change kept them together longer than they should have been.
马琳达下定了决心。那天晚上之后不久，她告诉迈克她想离婚。迈克称之为“气候离婚”。马琳达说不是。如果有的话，气候变化反而让他们在一起的时间比本应在一起的时间长。
I feel like I looked past and accepted so much more of what was bad, because it was in service of climate change. If he had been a QAnon conspirator, it would have been so easy for me to say, no, not doing that. But it's climate change. [LAUGHS]
我觉得我为了服务于气候变化，忽视并接受了太多糟糕的事情。如果他是一个“匿名者Q（QAnon）”阴谋论者，我说“不，我不做那个”会很容易。但这是气候变化。 [笑]
Mike and Malinda get divorced, and Mike moves just a few blocks away. The kids get to live with their mom full-time, as they'd hoped. And to establish some sort of new relationship with Mike, they try a couple rounds of family therapy. But according to the therapist notes, the first round crashes and burns because Mike keeps interrupting to explain climate change and the importance of his work to the therapist.
迈克和马琳达离婚了，迈克搬到了几个街区外。孩子们如愿以偿地和妈妈住在一起。为了建立某种新的关系，他们尝试了几轮家庭治疗。但根据治疗师的记录，第一轮以失败告终，因为迈克一直在打断对话，向治疗师解释气候变化以及他工作的重要性。
When they try again months later, Stella gets up the courage to tell Mike her big secret for the first time-- that she doesn't want to be a climate activist anymore, that she was only doing it because she felt he gave her no choice. Stella figured he'd say he was sorry, and she prepared herself to forgive him.
几个月后他们再尝试时，斯特拉鼓起勇气第一次告诉迈克她的大秘密——她不想再做气候活动家了，她只是因为觉得他没给她选择权才做的。斯特拉以为他会道歉，她准备好原谅他了。
But instead, Mike seemed angry. He did apologize. But the thing he apologized for was that he hadn't invited her to more climate events so that she'd be more emotionally invested in the cause, see it the way he did. A word to listeners who might be sensitive to this, this next part of the story mentions self-harm.
但相反，迈克似乎很生气。他确实道歉了。但他道歉的内容是：他没邀请她参加更多气候活动，导致她没能对这一事业产生更多情感投入，没能像他那样看待问题。给可能对此敏感的听众一个提示，故事的下一部分提到了自残。
I just remember feeling like I'm never going to escape him, and wanting everything to just be done with because I was so tired of having to explain these things that I'd gone through and having to think about him and having to talk about him and talk to him and having him not be who I needed him to be when I needed it. It just all became too much.
我只记得感觉好像我永远无法摆脱他，只想让一切彻底结束，因为我太累了，必须解释我所经历的这些事，必须想到他，必须谈论他，必须和他交谈，还得忍受他在我需要他的时候不是我需要的那个人。这一切实在是太沉重了。
About an hour and a half after the session with her dad, Stella attempted suicide. She spent the next eight days in the hospital. She told her mom to keep her dad away from her. She didn't even want him to know she was in there.
在那次和父亲的治疗后大约一个半小时，斯特拉试图自杀。她在医院住了八天。她告诉妈妈让爸爸离她远点。她甚至不想让他知道她在那里。
For me, it was the first time that I said no. It wasn't very dignified. I was kind of screaming and crying, like, no, don't let him in. Don't let him in. But I think having a complete break from him where he just stopped being at all a consideration for a week, but also having had the power to remove him, was really critical for me.
对我来说，这是我第一次说“不”。那不太体面。我当时在尖叫和哭泣，就像：不，不要让他进来。不要让他进来。但我认为，在那一周里完全摆脱他，让他不再成为考量的一部分，同时拥有将他隔离的权力，这对我来说确实至关重要。
I told Mike what Stella said, how their conversation in therapy was a breaking point for her just before her suicide attempt. He said he had no idea. He didn't remember apologizing for the wrong thing, for saying he was sorry he didn't get her more invested in climate work.
我告诉了迈克斯特拉说的话，她在治疗中的谈话是如何在她自杀企图前成为导火索的。他说他完全不知道。他不记得因为错误的事情而道歉，也不记得说过因为没让她对气候工作投入更多而感到抱歉。
I wish I could remember saying it. It sounds like the kind of stuff that would have come out of my mouth. And what a shitty thing when she needed something else.
我真希望我记得自己说过那样的话。这听起来确实像是从我嘴里说出来的那种话。当她需要别的什么东西时，那是多么糟糕的事情啊。
After that, Mike stopped trying to contact Stella. She didn't want him to, and the therapist said it could be dangerous for Stella. So he laid low, hoping the kids were OK and waiting for an invite to return to the family. Stella says that with the burden of fixing her relationship with her dad lifted, she started doing a lot better. Freed from climate work, she had time to do things that she actually liked, like reading fantasy novels. She also got a great therapist and started taking antidepressants, which she said have really helped.
那之后，迈克不再试图联系斯特拉。她不想让他这么做，治疗师也说这对斯特拉可能有危险。所以他保持低调，希望孩子们没事，等待着重回家庭的邀请。斯特拉说，随着修复与父亲关系的重担解除，她的情况开始好转。从气候工作中解放出来，她有时间做她真正喜欢的事情，比如读奇幻小说。她还找了一位很好的治疗师并开始服用抗抑郁药，她说这些确实非常有帮助。
And so with Stella feeling sturdier, it seemed like Mike and the kids might possibly find a way to rebuild, have a relationship of some kind, however fractured, until this next thing happened, which brought about the end of their world as they knew it. It was the fall of 2016, a little over a year after Stella's suicide attempt. And she reached out to ask for a meeting with her dad and Emrys and the therapist. In the meeting, Stella and Emrys told their dad that for them to consider having a relationship again, they needed him to stop doing climate work for a while. Here's Stella.
所以，随着斯特拉感觉更稳固，迈克和孩子们似乎有可能找到重建的方法，建立某种关系，无论多么破碎，直到下一件事发生，这彻底终结了他们所知的世界。那是2016年的秋天，斯特拉自杀企图后一年多。她主动要求和父亲、埃姆里斯以及治疗师开个会。会议中，斯特拉和埃姆里斯告诉父亲，他们若要考虑恢复关系，就需要他暂停气候工作一段时间。这是斯特拉。
He said he would. And it made me really happy. It felt like change.
他说他会暂停。这让我非常开心。感觉好像有希望改变。
Emrys was struck, too.
埃姆里斯也被触动了。
Maybe if he could get rid of that, then he really does care about us. Like, he must really love us if he's willing to give that up.
也许如果他能抛弃那个，那他确实在乎我们。就像，如果他愿意放弃那个，那他一定真的很爱我们。
A few weeks after that, after Mike told his kids he would stop doing climate activism, he did his most extreme climate action ever.
那之后几周，就在迈克告诉孩子们他会停止气候激进活动后，他实施了他有史以来最极端的气候行动。
Protesters manually turned off five oil pipelines today. One of the five protesters can be seen here turning off the pipeline valve in North Dakota. The group says--
抗议者今天手动关闭了五条输油管道。这五名抗议者中的一人可以在这里看到正在北达科他州关闭管道阀门。该团体表示——
Mike traveled to North Dakota, broke past the fence around the Keystone pipeline, and turned a valve, shutting off the flow of oil. He was arrested on-site and, at that point, charged with six felonies and two misdemeanors, which, combined, could land him in prison for more than 90 years.
迈克前往北达科他州，冲破了基石管道周围的栅栏，转动了阀门，切断了石油流。他当场被捕，当时被控六项重罪和两项轻罪，合并起来可能让他入狱超过90年。
I was mad. I was so mad.
我很生气。我真的非常生气。
Here's Emrys again.
这是埃姆里斯。
Man, I was pissed. That was the point where he's saying he would stop doing all this for us. And it's like, oh, he's going to prison.
天哪，我气疯了。那就是他所说的为了我们会停止这一切的时刻。结果却是：哦，他要坐牢了。
Here's Stella.
这是斯特拉。
That moment really just was it for me. I just didn't care anymore. It felt like relief because there was no small voice in my head saying, but he's your dad. You've got to love him. I was complete and whole and didn't need him and didn't want him.
那一刻对我来说确实就是终点。我再也不在乎了。这反而是一种解脱，因为我脑海中没有那种小声音在说：但他是你爸爸。你必须爱他。我感到完整和充实，不需要他，也不想他。
A bunch of the charges were either dismissed or amended, but Mike ended up spending six months in prison. He told me he didn't realize his kids were asking him to stop climate activism right then. He thought they meant someday. He said he had no idea this was the last straw for them. The valve-turning propelled Mike to fame in a new way, especially in their little green Seattle community, Malinda says.
多项指控要么被驳回，要么被修正，但迈克最终还是在监狱里待了六个月。他告诉我，他当时没意识到孩子们让他停止气候激进活动是“现在”。他以为他们指的是“某一天”。他说他完全不知道这是他们的底线。阀门事件以一种新的方式推动迈克出名，特别是在他们西雅图那个小小的环保社区，马琳达说。
Then the story was, he's a hero. Look what he's done. He's a hero. He's a hero. And there was an article in the local Seattle Magazine which painted him as this martyr and talked about how he sacrificed his relationship with his children for the planet. And they tried to say that, yeah, we couldn't fly anymore, and the marriage broke apart. And he had a quote saying something like, basically, I just annoyed the fuck out of them. I was like, that is so-- it is such a simple viewpoint. You didn't annoy the fuck out of us. You were as annoying as fuck. But you actually wounded us. You harmed us. You hurt us.
当时的报道是：他是个英雄。看看他做了什么。他是个英雄。他是个英雄。当地的《西雅图杂志》上有一篇文章把他描绘成殉道者，谈到他为了地球牺牲了与孩子们的关系。他们试图说：是的，我们不能坐飞机了，婚姻破裂了。他还有句引语大致是：基本上，我只是烦透了他们。我当时想：这真是——这是一个多么简单的观点。你不是烦透了我们。你是该死的令人讨厌。但你实际上伤害了我们。你损害了我们。你伤害了我们。
After the Seattle Magazine article came out, climate people would come up to Malinda and the kids and tell them they should really talk to Mike again, they should forgive him, because he's doing such important work. But Emrys doesn't see his work that way.
《西雅图杂志》的文章发表后，气候圈的人会走到马琳达和孩子们面前，告诉他们真的应该再和迈克谈谈，应该原谅他，因为他在做这么重要的事情。但埃姆里斯并不那样看待他的工作。
I think it's made it so that his name means something, but to very few people. It's a subset of people who are already inclined to that stuff. But he hasn't achieved anything. With his climate stuff, like I said, the valve-turning had no effect. The oil got there a couple hours later. He's made a series of empty gestures and spent years posturing as a hero and a family man and has just destroyed everything, I think, that was actually meaningful about his life.
我觉得这让他名字有了一些含义，但只对极少数人而言。那是一群本来就倾向于那些东西的人。但他什么都没实现。关于他的气候行为，正如我所说，转动阀门没有任何效果。石油几个小时后就流过去了。他做出了一系列空洞的姿态，多年来一直摆出英雄和慈父的姿态，但我认为，他已经摧毁了他生活中真正有意义的一切。
And I think, on some level, he knows that. And that's part of why he's so distressed about having lost his family. [SIGHS] I don't know. I guess I wish him well. But he can find meaning that isn't family, at this point, because we're done with him.
我想，在某种程度上，他自己也知道。这就是为什么他对失去家人感到如此痛苦的原因。 [叹气] 我不知道。我想我祝他好运。但此时此刻，他可以寻找家庭之外的意义，因为我们已经和他彻底结束了。
It's been nearly six years since Mike and Malinda got divorced. There's been essentially no contact between Mike and the kids since the valve-turning. The first time I talked to Mike, our interview lasted nine hours, mostly because almost every question I asked about his family, he ended up veering into climate change-- how bad things were, how no one was doing enough, how so many endemic species face extinction this century, a fact he told me four times in our interview.
迈克和马琳达离婚已经快六年了。自从阀门事件后，迈克和孩子们基本上没有任何联系。我第一次和迈克交谈时，采访持续了九个小时，主要是因为我问的关于他家庭的每一个问题，他最后都会转到气候变化上——形势有多糟糕，没人做得足够多，这个世纪有多少特有物种面临灭绝，他在采访中对我说了四遍这个事实。
He oscillated between extreme sadness over his nonexistent relationship with his kids to anger about the state of the world to agitated concern that I hadn't asked him any of the right questions yet, because I hadn't asked him about the science, about what it was going to take to change things.
他在对孩子们不存在的关系的极端悲伤，与对世界现状的愤怒，以及对我还没问对问题——因为我还没问他关于科学、关于需要做什么才能改变事情——的焦虑关切之间徘徊。
The morning after our interview, I woke up to an email from Mike. And he asked for a do-over. He said he'd accidentally gone into climate-rant mode instead of speaking as a dad. He said, quote, "I can't live with what I said. I can't. My ramblings sound monstrous and idiotic."
采访后的第二天早上，我醒来收到了迈克的一封邮件。他要求重来一次。他说他不小心进入了“气候咆哮模式”，而不是以父亲的身份说话。他说：引用，“我无法承受我所说的话。我不能。我的胡言乱语听起来既可怕又愚蠢。”
We tried again. He told me he didn't agree with his family that the problem was his personality and the way he handled his activism. He thought there were things he could have done better, but the real problem was that he and Malinda weren't on the same page. I told him I didn't think having two parents like him would have solved things with the kids. He didn't see it and didn't understand why his family couldn't have brought up how they were feeling with him.
我们又试了一次。他告诉我，他不同意他家人的看法，即问题在于他的个性和他处理激进活动的方式。他认为有些事情他本可以做得更好，但真正的问题是他和马琳达没有达成共识。我告诉他，我不认为有两个像他一样的家长能解决孩子们的问题。他没看出来，也不明白为什么他的家人不能向他表达他们的感受。
It's still news to me that they're afraid to talk to me about this stuff. I understand you've told me that there were these moments when I got angry, and I was really, really scary to them. And a big person and little kids-- totally get that and take responsibility for that. And yet, the apologies, the talks, the hugs, the bedtimes, the whatever, the living life that happened in between these whatever months of not being angry-- I guess I was under the illusion that they could talk to me about anything.
直到现在我才知道他们害怕和我谈论这些。我明白你告诉过我，我发火的时候，对他们来说真的很可怕。作为一个大个子对着小孩子——完全明白这一点，并对此承担责任。然而，在这些不生气的月份里发生的道歉、谈话、拥抱、睡前故事以及其他一切——我猜我当时处于一种幻觉中，以为他们什么都可以跟我谈。
It sounds like you didn't, at the time, realize how your behavior was impacting them. But there are a few interactions that seem like, even at the time, you would have understood the impact. Like, Emrys mentioned that you had called Stella a fucking bitch and a cunt when she was really little, like 10--
听起来你在当时并没有意识到你的行为对他们造成了什么影响。但有几次互动似乎在当时你就能明白影响。比如，埃姆里斯提到当斯特拉还很小时，大概10岁，你称她为“该死的婊子”和“荡妇”——
Yeah.
是的。
--which-- that feels like--
——这感觉像是——
That was horrible
那太可怕了。
--you would understand.
——你会明白的。
That was horrible. That was a nightmare. Yeah.
那太可怕了。那是一场噩梦。是的。
I could see how it'd be hard after that, after your dad calls you a cunt, to ever--
我能理解在你爸爸称你为“荡妇”之后，要再——
I would not--
我不会——
--say anything--
——说任何话——
Yes.
是的。
--to him to make him angry again.
——让他再次生气。
Yes, absolutely. Absolutely. And I did anything and everything I could afterwards to make it right. But come on. You're right. That was a thing that you can't take back. Yeah. So I live with that. [SIGHS] I'm broken. I don't know why I'm here. The thing I love the most is the thing I'm farthest from.
是的，绝对。绝对。事后我尽我所能去做任何弥补。但说真的，你是对的。那是一件你无法收回的事情。是的。所以我带着那个活着。 [叹气] 我破碎了。我不知道我为什么会在这里。我最爱的东西却是我离得最远的东西。
Things for Malinda and the kids are pretty good these days. Stella just turned 18. She says her climate nightmares only come every couple weeks instead of nightly. And she's off at college this fall, a milestone that, for a while, she never thought she'd reach. Emrys is 19. They work on a boat, teaching kids about marine life and maritime skills, a job they love, though they skip out on teaching the lessons about climate change. They said they're not ready to do that yet.
马琳达和孩子们的生活现在相当不错。斯特拉刚满18岁。她说她的气候恶梦现在每几周才出现一次，而不是每晚了。她今年秋天要去上大学，这是一个她一度认为自己永远达不到的里程碑。埃姆里斯19岁了。他们在船上工作，教孩子们关于海洋生物和海事技能的知识，这是一份他们热爱的工作，尽管他们跳过了关于气候变化的教学内容。他们说还没准备好去做那个。
While I was out in Seattle doing my interviews this summer, the Pacific Northwest was in the midst of the most extreme heat wave in the region's recorded history. Cable lines melted. Roads cracked in the heat. Over 100 people died. Stella told me that during the heat wave, she had to sit in her room and repeat to herself, things are bad, and there's nothing you can do about it, until the feeling passed. Emrys says, in low moments, their dad's voice pops into their head and tells them they haven't done anything with their life, that all they do is turn oxygen into carbon.
今年夏天我在西雅图进行采访时，太平洋西北地区正处于该地区有记录以来最极端的各种热浪中。电缆融化，道路在高温下开裂。超过100人死亡。斯特拉告诉我，热浪期间，她不得不坐在房间里对自己重复：情况很糟糕，你对此无能为力，直到那种感觉过去。埃姆里斯说，在低潮时，父亲的声音会浮现在脑海中，告诉他们一生一事无成，他们所做的只是把氧气变成碳。
Malinda and I did our interview in her office, the only place we could find central AC. It was 106 degrees outside. She told me the irony isn't lost on her. Mike was right about the climate. She said the hairs stand up on the back of her neck when she thinks about it. Malinda and the kids-- they try to block it out. But that's getting harder and harder.
马琳达和我在她的办公室进行了采访，那是我们能找到唯一有中央空调的地方。外面是106华氏度（约41摄氏度）。她告诉我这种讽刺并没有被她忽略。迈克关于气候的观点是对的。她说，当她想到这一点时，后背会起鸡皮疙瘩。马琳达和孩子们——他们试着不去想。但那正变得越来越难。
Aviva DeKornfeld. She's a producer on our show. Just a note. If you or somebody you know might need help, the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline is available 24/7 at 1-800-273-TALK. Again, that's 1-800-273-8255.
阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德。她是我们要节目的制片人。顺便说一下，如果你或你认识的人可能需要帮助，全国自杀预防生命热线提供24/7服务，电话是1-800-273-TALK。再次声明，号码是1-800-273-8255。
Act Two, Out of the Crying Pan and into the Fire. So there are all sorts of ways your world can end. And sometimes you want it to end, you need it to end, because that's the only way you can get to a new beginning. A couple weeks ago, I watched 15,000 people who wanted exactly that.
第二幕，《逃离哭泣的平底锅进入火中》。世界末日有很多种方式。有时你想要它结束，你需要它结束，因为那是你走向新开端的唯一途径。几周前，我看着15000人渴望的正是这一点。
OK. So we're standing in Fort Marcy Park in Santa Fe, New Mexico, under a 50-foot puppet.
好的，我们正站在新墨西哥州圣达菲的马西堡公园，在一个50英尺高的木偶下。
My guide for this is Alexi Horowitz-Ghazi, who grew up here in Santa Fe. He's also one of the hosts of NPR's Planet Money podcast. Technically speaking, the puppet is a marionette-- a ginormous one-- five stories tall, with a green, ghoulish head, on a hill towering over a baseball field and public park. His name is Zozobra.
我的向导是亚历克西·霍洛维茨-加齐，他在圣达菲长大。他也是NPR“星球金钱（Planet Money）”播客的主持人之一。严格来说，这是一个木偶——一个巨大的木偶——五层楼高，长着一个绿色、阴森的头，屹立在俯瞰棒球场和公园的小山上。他的名字叫佐佐布拉（Zozobra）。
He's the scapegoat of Santa Fe, New Mexico. Everybody puts-- they write down all of their anguish and sadness and misfortune that they've experienced in the last year. And they fill his whole body up. And then at the end of the night, he's going to be lit on fire and supposedly purge all of our sadness.
他是新墨西哥州圣达菲的替罪羊。每个人都会写下他们在过去一年中经历的所有痛苦、悲伤和不幸。他们填满他的全身。然后在夜晚结束时，他会被点燃，据说是为了净化我们所有的悲伤。
Alexi has been coming since grade school, when his class would visit during the day and watch them hoist Zozobra into the air. And the sadnesses that he would write down to be burned were about unrequited crushes and not getting the part in the student production of Grease. He shows me the ditch in the back of the park, this arroyo that his friends in high school would run through if they were sneaking in a bottle of tequila or something and wanted to avoid security.
亚历克西从小学起就开始来了，那时他的班级白天会来参观，看着他们把佐佐布拉吊到空中。他写的那些将被焚烧的悲伤事，都是关于单相思或者没得到学生版《油脂》音乐剧的角色。他带我看了公园后面的沟渠，那条高中朋友们如果偷带一瓶龙舌兰酒之类想躲避安保人员时会跑进去的小溪。
Yeah, kids do drugs. Kids get drunk. But also, the crowd turns really angry. And it's actually a scary-- it can be really scary out here. As much as it's a thing where people are releasing whatever has been making them sad throughout the year, it's also-- everyone directs their rage that they normally are hiding towards this puppet figure up on the hill. And people are screaming to burn him, and they're screaming expletives. And it's just a side of people you don't see, usually.
是的，孩子们会吸毒。孩子们会喝醉。但人群也会变得非常愤怒。这里实际上很可怕——有时真的会让人心惊肉跳。尽管人们来这里是为了释放一年来让他们悲伤的任何东西，但每个人也把他们平时隐藏的愤怒导向了山上那个木偶形象。人们尖叫着要烧死他，骂着脏话。这真的是你平时看不到的人的一面。
And you'll see everybody here. It's like, Santa Fe is a small town. And so I've seen teachers from high school or from elementary school as far gone as any of us.
你会在这里看到所有人。圣达菲是个小镇。所以我见过高中或小学的老师，和我们所有人一样颓废。
Drunk.
喝醉了。
When Alexi says you see everybody here, just to put that in perspective, Santa Fe's population is around 80,000. 60,000 people usually come to Zozobra. Though, this year, because of COVID, they limited attendance to a fourth of that. It's tons of families, maybe half Latino. The sadnesses that people write down to be burned are officially called glooms. And they're collected in boxes in town before the event and at the event.
当亚历克西说你在这里能看到所有人时，为了说明一下，圣达菲的人口大约8万。通常有6万人会来看佐佐布拉。不过，今年因为疫情，出席人数限制在四分之一。这里有大量的家庭，也许一半是拉美裔。人们写下要被焚烧的悲伤事被正式称为“阴霾（glooms）”。它们在活动前会在镇上的盒子里收集，在活动中也会收集。
Come right up! We've got plenty of paper, plenty of pens, and plenty of boxes. You've got the gloom, we have the receptacle. That doesn't work. It's just--
直接过来！我们有很多纸、很多笔和很多盒子。你有阴霾，我们有容器。那句不顺口。这只是——
You're going to have to make it rhyme.
你得让它押韵。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
You've got the gloom, we've got the room.
你有阴霾，我们有空间。
There you go. Do you want to [INAUDIBLE].
这不就对了。你想 [听不清] 吗。
As I'm sure you know, it has been a boffo year for gloom. Lots of people wrote notes about COVID and loved ones they lost, but also about other big glooms-- climate, Afghanistan. Alexi has got some family in Kabul that he's worried about, and he put that into his note for Zozobra, along with some other people he wanted to remember. People write down all kinds of personal stuff.
我相信你也知道，今年是“阴霾”的大年。很多人写了关于疫情和他们失去的挚爱，也写了关于其他巨大的阴霾——气候、阿富汗。亚历克西在喀布尔有一些亲戚让他很担心，他把这些写进了给佐佐布拉的字条里，还写了一些他想纪念的其他人。人们写下各种各样的个人琐事。
Right now, my dad is in a psych hospital this week, and I like-- well, I'm picking him up tomorrow. But I wrote in something for him.
现在，我爸爸这周在精神病院，我喜欢——嗯，我明天要去接他。但我为他写了一些东西。
So I just put-- I know this is a little personal story. But I put, my ex left me, my uncle and dad passed away, and then my friends were ghosting me. And then I said, 2021 has got to go.
所以我只是写了——我知道这是一个有点私人的故事。但我写了：我的前任离开我，我的叔叔和爸爸去世了，然后我的朋友开始躲着我。然后我说，2021年必须滚蛋。
At the gloom-box tables, I saw an eight-year-old boy, Julian, who carefully wrote, on a slip of paper, "I miss Mom. I miss the house." His dad, Joaquin, explained.
在阴霾箱旁，我看到一个八岁的男孩朱利安，他在一张纸条上小心翼翼地写道：“我想念妈妈。我想念那所房子。”他的爸爸华金解释说。
Basically what happened was, because of COVID and everything, losing my job, I wasn't able to make the payments on the house, and I ended up losing it. So that's about it.
基本上发生的事情是，因为疫情和其他一切，失去了工作，我无法支付房贷，最终房子没了。就这样。
Yeah.
是的。
Julian's mom moved to Colorado. In the past, people have brought legal papers from disastrous lawsuits to go into Zozobra for burning. This year, Kay Arnold's medical diagnosis made it into the pile. Kay was diagnosed with stage-four breast cancer in May. She lives in Texas and drove in with her daughter to watch it burn.
朱利安的妈妈搬到了科罗拉多州。过去，人们曾把灾难性诉讼的法律文件放进佐佐布拉里焚烧。今年，凯·阿诺德的医学诊断也进入了这一堆。凯在五月被诊断出患有四期乳腺癌。她住在德克萨斯州，和她的女儿开车来观看它燃烧。
Stage-four breast cancer is not, at this time, curable. So I'm responding well. I'm being treated. But what else are you going to do with a cancer diagnosis, right? Stick it in a big, giant zombie, set it on fire.
四期乳腺癌目前无法治愈。所以我反应还不错。我正在接受治疗。但面对癌症诊断，你还能做什么，对吧？把它塞进一个巨大的僵尸里，然后点把火烧了。
What do you think it's going to be like to see it burn?
你觉得看到它燃烧会是什么感觉？
I think it's going to be invigorating. I'm already on the verge of tears. Yeah.
我觉得会令人振奋。我已经在流泪的边缘了。是的。
Why does it work to burn something in an effigy?
为什么要通过焚烧雕像来处理？
I just think it helps you to feel like it's gone. I don't know. That's a good question. It feels like you're doing something, especially about something that maybe you can't do anything about. I don't know. When you can't do anything, why not set it on fire?
我只是觉得这有助于让你感觉它消失了。我不知道。这是个好问题。感觉你是在做些什么，尤其是在面对那些也许你无能为力的事情时。我不知道。当你无能为力时，为什么不把它点燃呢？
She'd already done everything reasonable for her illness-- doctors, medicines. Time to try something unreasonable. Katarina Valdez brought her wedding dress to be burned. One of the organizers actually sent her a photo of the dress hanging inside Zozobra that she showed me on her phone.
她已经为她的疾病做了所有合理的事情——医生、药物。是时候尝试一些不理智的事情了。卡塔琳娜·瓦尔德斯带来了她的婚纱要焚烧。其中一位组织者其实给她发了一张婚纱挂在佐佐布拉里面的照片，她在手机上给我看了。
So that's the back of Zozobra. And then my dress is right there at the bottom with the envelope that I put-- I put a letter from myself just saying goodbye to my past, that time in my life.
所以那是佐佐布拉的背面。然后我的婚纱就在底部，还有我放的信封——我放了一封写给自己的信，就是告别我的过去，告别我生命中的那段时光。
It's interesting. It's just hanging there on a hanger.
很有意思。它就挂在那儿，在衣架上。
Yeah, it's on a hanger. It really, literally is on a plastic hanger hanging in Zozobra.
是的，它在衣架上。它真的、字面上就在一个塑料衣架上挂在佐佐布拉里面。
Also in that envelope, some photos that she never wants to see again and a promise ring given to ask forgiveness, Katarina says, for something she never should have forgiven. She was married for seven years.
在那个信封里还有一些她再也不想看到的照片，以及为了请求原谅而给的订婚戒指，卡塔琳娜说，请求原谅她本不该原谅的事情。她结婚七年。
What's it like to see that there?
在那里看到那个是什么感觉？
It's really exciting. I'm sick of seeing it in my mom's closet. And I've been divorced for three years, and I want to move on. I have three beautiful children that are finally in a really healthy and safe environment with us. And they're thriving at school. I have a beautiful, amazing new partner. He's going to start giggling. We've been dating for seven months. [CHUCKLES] And so it's the perfect time to do this.
真的很令人兴奋。我厌倦了在妈妈的壁橱里看到它。我已经离婚三年了，我想继续前进。我有三个漂亮的孩子，终于在一个非常健康和安全的环境中和我们在一起了。他们在学校里茁壮成长。我有一个漂亮、惊人的新伴侣。他会开始咯咯笑的。我们约会七个月了。 [轻笑] 所以现在是做这件事的最佳时机。
She'd love to bring the kids with her to see the dress burn. But she said they're with their dad, actually at Zozobra somewhere, right then.
她很想带孩子们来看着裙子燃烧。但她说他们和爸爸在一起，其实就在佐佐布拉的某处，就在那时。
And I don't know if he knows now. I didn't tell him, but I'm sure my kids did.
我不知道他现在知不知道。我没告诉他，但我确定我的孩子们告诉他了。
Wait, wait. I just want to look out on the field. So somewhere in this field--
等等，等等。我只想看看场地上。所以在这个场地的某个地方——
Yeah.
是的。
--is your ex-husband with your three kids--
——是你的前夫和你的三个孩子——
My three children. Yes.
我的三个孩子。是的。
--who have definitely told him that your wedding dress is in there.
——他们肯定告诉他你的婚纱在里面。
Yeah. [CHUCKLES]
是的。 [轻笑]
She said, if it upsets him, she's sorry. But she needed to turn the dress into ashes.
她说，如果这让他心烦，她很抱歉。但她需要把这件裙子变成灰烬。
(CHANTING) Burn him! Burn him! Burn him! Burn him! Burn him!
（齐声喊）烧了他！烧了他！烧了他！烧了他！烧了他！
The sun sets, and the crowd starts chanting for the big moment. I watch the burn with Katarina and her boyfriend.
太阳落山了，人群开始为那一刻高呼。我和卡塔琳娜以及她的男朋友一起看着焚烧。
I'm a lot more nervous than I thought I was going to be.
我比我预想的要紧张得多。
Costumed dancers set off fires in a line across the stage and taunt Zozobra, who moans and waves his arms in protest. A dancer in red carrying torches sets him on fire. Skyrockets shoot off. Orange light starts to flicker inside Zozobra's body.
装扮好的舞者在舞台上排成一排点燃火焰，挑衅着佐佐布拉，他呻吟着挥舞着手臂抗议。一名携带火炬的红衣舞者点燃了他。冲天炮射出。橙色的光开始在佐佐布拉体内闪烁。
There he goes! There he goes! Baby, there he goes! Oh my gosh. Baby, there he goes. [CHUCKLES] Oh my gosh. Baby, there his dress goes! Baby!
他去了！他去了！宝贝，他去了！哦，天哪。宝贝，他去了。 [轻笑] 哦，天哪。宝贝，他的裙子去了！宝贝！
Zozobra's dress basically makes up the bottom half of his body. And of course, inside his dress is Katarina's dress.
佐佐布拉的裙子基本上组成了他身体的下半部分。当然，在他裙子里面的是卡塔琳娜的裙子。
Wait. Look. Now there's fire inside the dress.
等等。看。现在裙子里面有火了。
There it goes! Baby, there it goes! There's his skirts. And that's where my dress was.
去了！宝贝，去了！那是他的裙摆。那就是我的裙子所在的地方。
Zozobra flails his arms just a little while longer, and then it's done.
佐佐布拉挥舞手臂又持续了一小会儿，然后就结束了。
There it goes.
去了。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
He just collapsed to the ground.
他瘫倒在地上。
Yeah, our glooms are gone. And that's it. Our glooms are gone, and we move on. [CHUCKLES]
是的，我们的阴霾消失了。就这样。我们的阴霾消失了，我们继续前进。 [轻笑]
You feel good.
你感觉很好。
Yeah. Yeah, I feel amazing.
是的。是的，我感觉棒极了。
And you feel different than you did earlier.
而且你感觉和早些时候不同了。
Yeah. Yeah, this is what I hoped for. So it worked. It worked. So I'm excited to see what the morning brings.
是的。是的，这就是我所期望的。所以它生效了。它生效了。所以我很期待明天会带来什么。
Everyone Alexi and I talked to afterward said they felt different, less encumbered. But nobody could explain exactly why. A few said it's just primal-- throwing something into fire to vanquish it. Even Kay, the woman from Texas who burned her medical records, told me she knows her diagnosis. She knows she's going back to the doctors and the medicines. But even she felt more hopeful, like a fresh start.
亚历克西和我交谈过的每个人事后都说他们感觉不同了，没那么沉重了。但没人能准确解释原因。几个人说这只是原始本能——把东西扔进火里去征服它。即使是来自德克萨斯的凯，那位焚烧医疗记录的女性，也告诉我她知道自己的诊断。她知道她会回到医生和药物身边。但即便如此，她也感到更有希望了，就像一个全新的开始。
As people started to clear out of the park, a handful gathered around the smoking embers of Zozobra to roast marshmallows on the flames of their unhappy year, welcoming the new one with burnt, sugary sweetness.
当人们开始清理公园时，一小群人聚集在佐佐布拉冒烟的余烬周围，在他们不幸一年的火焰上烤棉花糖，用烧焦的、含糖的甜味迎接新的一年。
[MUSIC - HELLOGOODBYE, "LET IT BURN"]
[音乐 - HELLOGOODBYE, "让它燃烧"]
Well, today's program was produced by Miki Meek and Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Sean Cole, Damien Graef, Seth Lind, Mary Marge Locker, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alissa Shipp, Jessica Suriano, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Chloee Weiner. Our managing editor this week-- Diane Wu. Senior editor-- David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor-- Emanuele Berry.
好的，今天的节目由米基·米克和阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德制作。筹备今天节目的成员包括比姆·阿德温米、肖恩·科尔、达米安·格拉夫、塞思·林德、玛丽·玛吉·洛克、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、艾丽莎·希普、杰西卡·苏里亚诺、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和克洛伊·魏纳。本周我们的主编——戴安·吴。高级编辑——大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑——伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Rebecca Huntley, who you heard in the opening of our program. One of the things that she did after her wake-up moment is write a book. It's called How to Talk About Climate in a Way That Makes a Difference, which is where we first heard of her.
特别感谢今天节目开头提到的丽贝卡·亨特利。她在觉醒时刻后做的事情之一就是写了一本书。书名是《如何以有意义的方式谈论气候》，我们就是在那儿第一次了解到她的。
Also thanks today to Brett Wean, Kacy Suther, Kristy Drutman, Juliet Liu, Beth Haase, Fred Ehresmann, Lisa Jaramillo, Desiree Lira, and Julia Goldberg, who was manning the gloom boxes at Zozobra. Our website-- ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
还要感谢今天提供帮助的布雷特·温、卡西·萨瑟、克里斯蒂·德鲁特曼、朱丽叶·刘、贝丝·哈斯、弗雷德·埃里斯曼、丽莎·哈拉米略、德西雷·利拉和在佐佐布拉负责阴霾箱的朱莉娅·戈德堡。我们的网站——ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流电台PRX分发到各公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He was making fun of me this week because he found out that I am really into skateboards. Though, I have to say, not the entire skateboard, OK? I don't care about the deck or the wheels.
照例，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他这周取笑我，因为他发现我真的很迷滑板。不过，我得说，不是整个滑板，好吗？我不关心滑板面或轮子。
Wow, you're super passionate about trucks. I just didn't know you're so into trucks. Was this always a thing? I think it's really great.
哇，你对滑板支架真是超级热衷啊。我只是不知道你这么迷恋支架。这一直是你的一项爱好吗？我觉得真的很棒。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》，带来更多故事。